item number
scp-1 object class
safe formerly ketter
special containment procedures following
the recent investigations of dr robert
montauk
no action is currently needed to contain
scp-1
it is functionally self-containing and
any foundation interference may harm
or alter its containment irreversibly
no foundation personnel are to engage
with any new matters related to scp-1
with the exception of related anomalies
already in foundation containment
description scp-1 is an entity
ordinarily referred to
as the scarlet king scp-1 is currently
located in several alternate dimensions
simultaneously and is unable to enter
the prime dimension
however it is believed to have been
repeatedly attempting entry for a period
of under 300 years
previously several thousand scp-1's
physical
mental and conceptual properties are
unknown to the foundation
nevertheless it continues to assert a
strong influence on a number of
individuals and events
within the prime dimension it is
believed that scp-1's existence
represents an ongoing but dormant
tashkent class
cross-pollination scenario should scp-1
enter the prime timeline
an irreparable alteration to normalcy
will occur
containment of scp-1 is however
unnecessary
previously top priority any attempt to
alter scp-1's classification or object
class
will result in immediate dismissal from
the o5 council
references in art and oral tradition to
scp-1
appear across a wide variety of human
and non-human cultures across the
universe
including in communities which have
never previously had any contact with
one another
common descriptions within these
traditions are of a red creature of the
men's size
ordinarily wearing a golden crown or
other headdress signifying royalty
although the names ascribed to scp-1
vary the majority contain
two elements a word signifying some form
of royalty combined with a word
signifying the color red
cultures which do not have a concept of
the color red but
follow this naming pattern will
universally use a color
analogous to the english concept of the
color red
most personnel except those working on
anomalies related to scp-1
possess no knowledge of the entity as
part of scp-2317's containment
procedures
level 4 personnel are to be informed
that scp-23
is in fact scp-1 the truth of this is
unknown although it is a hypothesis
which has received strong support
among several members of the council the
apparently multi-dimensional nature of
scp-1
however renders the possibility of
scp-2317 being any more than a single
aspect of scp-1
unlikely it is unknown when scp-1 was
discovered
the loss of several archives containing
the foundation's origins in the 1889
snarling coup has prevented a full
reconstruction of events
although an investigation shortly
following a variety of groups dedicated
to bringing scp-1 into the prime
dimension
have existed over the years the most
recent of these has been the children of
the scarlet king
which was destroyed in a joint goc scp
operation
in january 2018. its former leader
depeche spivak
is currently in foundation custody under
the designation
person of interest 3172
update 1st of june 2018.
scp-1 has recently been the subject of
an extensive investigation by dr robert
montauk project lead on scp-1
231 and 2317 and divisor of procedure
110 montauk
based on the results of this
investigation scp-1 has been downgraded
to safe
following a decision taken by the o5
council upon the request of the former
o513
a number of documents related to this
investigation can be found below
in order to provide context and further
information pertaining to this theory
these have been curated categorized and
included by the former o513 herself
with the permission of o51 in order to
provide some context
to this re-evaluation phase one
blood document one the following is an
interview between dr robert montauk
and poi 3172
date 1st of april 2018 interviewer
dr robert montauk interviewee poi 3172
location site 713 interview room 2.
again dr montauk i don't understand what
you people want from me
hello to you too i'm sorry to do this to
you again
i think it's silly too to be honest what
we want from your answers
it's been what weeks months you've
dragged me down here into one of your
interview rooms and asked me these
endless questions well you are one of
your lackings
i'm sorry if you'd be made to feel
uncomfortable it wasn't my intention
but it's hard to keep tabs on everything
anymore
never guards been treating you badly in
any way no no not really
i can't really complain it's just their
eyes
they look so dead so cold
if you like i can rearrange some
personnel and put someone else on your
security detail
we're a bit short staffed around here at
the moment and a lot of our best folks
are away
and then there's the paperwork and the
endless oversight there's been some
trouble with
well you don't need to know about that
you weren't what i
expected you know you thought the
foundation will be different
no i thought you would be you'd heard of
me
of what you've done procedure 110
montauk
well the people in my circles have done
some dark things in their time
but that i really did what was necessary
mr spivak
as a foundation researcher and as
someone who doesn't want to see his
loved ones die
yes that's very like the foundation
isn't it everything
done is just defined by what is
necessary you see the world
the people moving through it living
lives touched only by totalizing
universal laws of society and physics
and everything has to be channeled
through those laws
and that which lies outside is to be
contained it's also very simple
you wouldn't say that if you worked here
some of us called you evil
i don't think that's quite it that's
kind of you to say and to tell you the
truth i don't think you're quite what i
expected either
especially given your reputation i've
been told i am a hard person to get
along with
too cryptic they say one person even
called me airy
i don't think i'd call you harry your
head may be in the clouds but
you seem to be maddeningly smug about it
granted not as smug as some of the
delusional cults who have passed through
here
i suppose i should be thankful for that
at least i'll
try not to take that as an insult but
this is what i don't understand
your procedure one ten month talk it's
not i can't discuss that i'm afraid
we must get on time and tide and all our
rubbish
please tell me what the children of the
scarlet king's overall intention was
the children are dead there's not much
left to tell you
i would like to hear things in your own
words then i suppose you could say
that our intention was to save the world
and how are you planning to go about
doing that by bringing the scarlet king
into this reality of course
you know this already but how would that
save the world
doctor is this really necessary
he took away his daughters years ago and
ended up killing most of them
you have already annihilated our society
and i'm sure you know all about what
went on within it
we worship the king pretending he was
satan or some other ancient god or evil
our inner circle believed in violation
as the ultimate holy act
we failed you and the book burn has
destroyed us
and the matter has been put to rest you
seem awfully calm while describing the
destruction of your life's work
what else can i do i know how this is
going to play out
maybe i always did why do you refer to
the global occult coalition as
the book burgers were you and your group
affiliated with the serpent's hand
that's it's complicated
it's a simple enough question but there
isn't a simple answer
still yes we were affiliated with the
serpent's hand
most of us passed through there one time
or another they will to disavow us of
course
if you speak to them about us they're
not monsters like we are
they have moral precepts you see the
whole point is to look for wonder and
since they see no wonder in the king
they repudiate us utterly
but they know deep down they need us
they need you what for
for the same reason they let us live we
raided the library
fought them skirmished with them they
had a huge quantity of dirt on us
far more than you do but they never
finished the job
they're as bad as you jailers in their
own way the same compartmentalization
the same singular goals their existence
is based in nothing concrete
the empty time of history that's all
indeed they came into being the same
time as you
you're more similar than you realize
that's impossible
the serpent's hand has been documented
as existing long before the foundation
in any angle no no you missed the point
the library's always been there yes
but not the hand the hand was something
new
like you all are you think anybody ever
cared about wonder in the old days
nobody cared about wonder they cared
about food
family and blood what's that supposed to
mean
it means no you wouldn't get it anyway
but the hand would
i think even the book burners do in
their own way
but the hand is scared they try to blot
us
out forget us we're what they should be
but never can be you see look depression
i have tried to make things more
comfortable for you
but we need some give and take you're
speaking in cliched cryptic riddles
i want some answers i can't tell you
everything
you wouldn't treat the information
properly you treat it as scientific fact
something to be swallowed understood
contextualized
and what's wrong with that why are you
doing this doctor
why are you dredging this stuff up again
i shouldn't tell you but
ah screw it i'm tired of this i've been
working on a cp-1 for two decades
project lead for almost nine years after
i came up with a procedure
i don't know i'm tired everywhere i turn
i see the scarlet king
but nothing about it makes any sense
some bighorn devil arcane blood god
it's all so small so obvious the
foundation has changed in the last
decade
you see we've faced conceptual demons
malevolent genre dwellers sevenfold
destroyers
all of which are far worse than some old
sacrificed deity
but there behind everything i see this
smiling fire that dread
that old dread it lingers and this is
despite seeing horrors far less easy and
far more subtle
trying to break the world on a daily
basis i just want to understand i
suppose
peel back the layers the tails upon
contradictory tails and find out who he
really
is you're being awfully candid
to be honest i've stopped caring
this job gets to you the things you have
to do
the regrets well i'm too high up for
anybody to touch me now
and i've run into too many dead ends to
get hung up over a protocol by this
point
just tell me something dipash anything
okay look i like you mom talk
you must be a cold-blooded bastard
somewhere in there but you wouldn't have
come up with
well who am i to judge okay i'll tell
you where to start
i'm all ears there are three things to
understand about the scarlet king
three laws which when put together make
up a complete picture
one is the law of blood one is the law
of concrete
and one is the law of howling
three laws huh that the king set down
for his followers
or that were imposed upon him both
the first was his law the second was
somebody else's
and as for the third well
you'll find out about the third when
you've cracked the first two
very cryptic that's all i can tell you
for now
you need to learn in the proper way
that's really all you'll give that's all
all right depeche good talking with you
as ever
document two the following is an extract
from the memoirs of one jack
hurst a defector from the children of
the scarlet king
hearst was a high-level reality bender
capable of entering the bodies of humans
in the past
and experiencing their thoughts and
emotions first hand
the following is a description of what
hearst called the battle of gemilith
purportedly a battle between scp-1 and
his followers
against a group called the children of
the urns hearst apparently experienced
the battle from the perspective of a
foot soldier in
scp-1's army these memoirs were written
shortly before hurst's death in 1976.
they were among the first documents
consulted by dr montauk
during his investigation the fortress
was monumental
made of volcanic rock and jagged iron
and built into a vast mountain
every measurement every angle was
calculated to promote the king's
ideology
the steel slats and bars may have seemed
to be jutting out in random half-sworn
directions
but if you could see the hole then you'd
see this symmetry
it was a perfect expression of cosmic
order expressed in endless sevens
it's a tough trip to remember but bits
and pieces come back
we were slaves i think we had been taken
from a far-off land
the nobility looked down upon us with
cruel eyes
but the king didn't care he rewarded us
and so we were the instruments of his
rule
when a village required the justice of
the king we would descend upon them with
blood and iron
the villagers feared us and that felt
right to me
but when the horde came with fire and
burning and their cries of freedom
the villagers were still just as scared
as they had been of us
that was not the fear of their master i
think but the fear of anarchy
they did not know which way to turn in
the end
most betrayed us many had their
daughters taken by our master
old rights blood rights
arcane rights but we stood upon the
battlement
loyal to the last our hearts bursting
with happiness
at the rightness of it all i'm still not
sure exactly what was going on
it was all so chaotic and full of red
smoke
but i could feel my host's bloodlust
we stood and watched and waited
the sound of rubble and explosions came
from across the hill
and the last battle begun then
something strange happened my host
suddenly felt afraid
and he and i were somewhere else the sky
was not red but
black i was not a slave but part of a
conscripted rabble
the peasants looked up at us they were
all starving
they held out their hands begging
pleading
praying the wind was their master and it
screamed at them
the horde was coming but they too were
starving
then the scene flickered black and i was
in my host again
under a scarlet sky the king's voice
raged
the rabble of his armies was fleeing to
the gates but they would not open
our arrows coated in flame and pitch
flew back again
but the horde was undaunted in my mind i
could see
nothing but the fire the fire of the
king
i drew my sword we all
drew our swords we all charged into the
fray
and then as it were the scene changed
again
there were no battlements only the dark
sky and the wind and a
more ragged and lonely sky the peasants
pleaded
the nomads laughed cheered
wept the wind will rage no more
they said the two scenes shifted
in and out a red fort bled into a black
field i have ruminated on it a long time
but i think they were the same battle
seen through two different eyes or at
least the memories of two different
battles the whole thing felt strange it
was not like most of my trips
it was a half cacophony two ideas
ripping at each other
there was a timeline showing what really
happened in that blackened wasteland
and there was one that had been made to
be true
imposed throughout time on the truth
the last thing i remember was being
sliced by a nomad sword
of a frail urn being held high of seven
brides being ripped from a castle
or they were ripped from a field taken
as the spoils of war by some
obscure tribe in some lost step
i remember the king screaming writhing
thrashing as he was sealed and then
i died and woke up back at the ritual
for a second i wondered if the others
had just made up the king
and sent some image of him back to the
past
but i don't think that was true they
lacked the power
and besides it was never a total lie
there was something in that wicked wind
that reminded me of some of the older
rituals
it was then that i decided to leave the
children
i went that night without a word they
didn't stop me
probably figured it wasn't worth the
effort
they were so certain in the success
of their mission but i wanted no part in
that anymore the things i saw were based
upon the law of blood
and i can only pray that they never come
to pass
document three the following is a log of
all known attempts by anomalous groups
to force scp-1's entry
into the prime dimension since the
containment of scp-231
date the 1st of march 2009 group of
interest
provisional children of the scarlet king
details of attempt
summoning attempt was performed by the
ritual of smearing blood and then the
destruction of rubble recovered from the
demolition of the cochrane gardens
housing project complex
in st louis missouri it is believed that
the children of the scarlet king
manipulated state officials
into the demolition over the course of
several years and that this splinter
group continued their work as the
original children
went into decline result attempt
prevented by a foundation raid
date 12th of may 2012 group of interest
red guards details of attempt appeared
to be using the blood
bones and spinal fluid of several
animals combined with ritual
chanting to create a portal to scp-1 a
large number of scp foundation logos
carved out of bone were placed around
the ritual site in a defensive position
these logos were slightly incorrectly
carved
result attempt not detected by any group
of interest
and came extremely close to success
however
it appears a critical mistake in the
words of ritual instead resulted in a
large explosive blast
and destroyed all the assembled members
of the guards it remains unknown why the
guards apparently wished to invoke
foundation protection
for their ceremony date february 7th
2014 group of interest global occult
coalition
details of attempt unknown result
unknown
but did not succeed global occult
coalition records pertaining to the
incident are missing
with the exception of the name operation
historical frontier
with the mission statement to exacerbate
tensions of historical time
in order to bring forth and destroy a
significant occult threat
it is believed that several global
occult coalition operatives were killed
in the attempt date first of january
2017
group of interest army of the new dawn
details of attempt
attempt involved the ritual burning of
several calendars
adhering to the gregorian calendar while
members of the group
raised up blood-soaked calendars
adhering to the julian
hijiri and persian solar systems to an
effigy of scp-1
result attempt prevented by members of
the serpent's hand
all materials were recovered and taken
to the wonders library
date 17th of september 2017
group of interest the serpent's hat
details of attempt
largely unknown details are unclear but
it is believed it involved the highly
selective destruction of particular
books
within the wonders library result
attempt was purportedly foiled due to a
schism in the group
the resulting casualties severely
damaged the library
phase two concrete
document four the following is an
interview between robert montauk and poi
3172
date 14th of april 2018 interviewer
dr robert montauk interviewee poi
3172 location site 713
interview room 2. hello again robert
hello depeche i looked up your laws
i'm afraid i'm not the wise you'll get
there
what did you find the law of blood is
referenced a few times in quite a few
places but i couldn't find any concrete
information
i worried you wouldn't there was only
one source of real use
a description of something called the
battle of gemaleth
written by a defector from the children
yes i read his memoir once the only
genuine witness of the king's ceiling
although a rather unreliable one oh
he embellished he didn't leave straight
away
i stumbled upon some early draft in his
things shortly before he left
i was young back then and i remember how
passionately he argued after his vision
said we got the king all wrong and that
he wasn't a demon or a monarch
but then he was a voice on the wind
when i was older and had figured it all
out i was surprised how close he got to
a fuller understanding
he just wasn't quite there
i should have guessed he was a liar he's
not a liar
exactly just a little lost
and you only have my word for it doctor
which the foundation has made abundantly
clear it
doesn't trust there's no reason to doubt
you
what do you have to lose you seem as
eager for me to learn the truth as i am
true and on that note
i have a question if i may
shoot the longer i keep you talking the
greater the chance you'll slip up and
tell me something you shouldn't
do you know why the procedure 110
montauk
actually works
sorry i can't talk to you about that
that's okay
i think i know the answer anyway tell me
did you lose someone i don't know what
you mean
i'm sorry to bring back painful memories
but i have looked at the foundation
archives too you know
it was necessary back in the day to
check up on what your lot were doing to
his daughters
i know that your brother stop talking
this interview is not about my private
affairs
i'm sorry doctor i didn't mean please
state the meaning of this
law of blood isn't it obvious it's the
way the scarlet king ruled
there was order but it was through the
imposition of an
iron will on the peasantry through
armies of slaves through a nobility
bread to be cruel
the realities of the world of his day in
his corner of the globe
what does this have to do with sc with
scp-1's nature
what are these other laws i suggest you
look into the second i don't have time
to play your games
tell me now poi 3172 or you will be
escorted to solitary
oh dr montauk i am sorry but you must
look for the lore of concrete
that is all this interview is terminated
document five the following is a page
from the 1891 report
of agent de beauvoir on lost foundation
archives following the 1889
snarling coup the report was lost
shortly after de bolvoir's termination
in 1895 along with several other
documents from the foundation archives
this page was recovered through unknown
means by dr montauk
no other materials from these data
losses have been found
summary the documents lost are extremely
extensive
covering a wide range of data concerning
the foundation's early history
in particular several documents related
to scp-1 have gone missing
however my investigations have provided
me with a great deal of information
and i believe that i can say with some
certainty that the historical record
as stated in scranton's comprehensive
history remains broadly intact
albeit with some modifications i will
detail below
scranton's work states that the
foundation was founded in 1824
by the merger of 13 worldwide
organizations
with a particular interest in preventing
awareness of anomalous activities
the most prominent of these were the
foundation of the secure containment of
the unnatural
the devon e jedui the united sites of
the department of unexplained affairs
the council of five overseers and the
committee of paranormal ethics
scranton goes on to tell us that this
was done in response to the threat posed
by scp-1
and that the early foundation had an
extensive role to play in that anomaly's
containment
however the documents i have before me
present a rather
different picture it appears that the
foundation was not founded in response
to scp-1 at all
indeed i cannot find any references to
the present scp-1
prior to 1826 it appears to have been a
highly publicized attack
by scp-173 in new york which was the
initial impetus for the foundation's
formation
scp-173 still unresolved containment
breach in 1854
is i believe the reason for the
alteration of the record
scranton's embarrassment act
document six the following is a table
compiled by dr montauk
it shows a series of votes passed by the
o5 council
correlated with incidents potentially or
certainly involving scp-1
date of vote 9th of july 1844
description of vote vote to officially
standardize documentation across the scp
foundation
passed 13-0 related scp-1
incident a series of hymns devoted to
scp-1 heard outside
site 1. date of vote first of february
1857 description of vote vote to
standardize containment procedures for
scp-1
passed 12-1 related scp-1 incident
all members of the o5 council reported
dreaming of an unidentified man
of south asian origin weeping
date of vote the 9th of november 1895
description of vote vote on the
termination of agent de beauvoir
passed 6'5 to abstentions related scp-1
incident a large quantity of
blood-stained sheets of paper with the
words scp-1
written in blood over each sheet
spontaneously manifested in the bedrooms
of all members of the o5 council
the blood was later identified to belong
to agent de beauvoir
and an unknown species of poultry date
of vote
10th of october 1902 description of vote
vote on the implementation of the site
system passed
10 to 2 1 abstention related scp-1
incident a location in north america saw
sudden
and unexplained wildfires residents
reported seeing dragons made of fire
and a horned crown appear in the night
sky above the area
the wildfires were found in 2007 to have
begun at the location
of the futures site 19. date of vote
23rd of january 1922 description of vote
vote on the containment procedures for
scp-2317
passed four to three six abstentions
related scp-1 incident
several cracks appeared in the earth
near containment area 179
red smoke was seen pouring out of each
crack for seven
minutes before the cracks abruptly
closed
date of vote 8th of february 2011.
description of vote vote to unify the
project per views of scp-1
scp-231 and scp-2317t
passed 10-2 one abstention related scp-1
incident
a series of hymns devoted to scp-1 heard
outside site 1
interspersed with the sound of laughter
date of vote
31st of march 2018 description of vote
vote on the object class
reclassification of scp-2317
passed 9-4 related scp-1 incident
several inter-dimensional rifts open
outside containment area 179
these rifts alternated between opening
on universe kappa erakesh
and opening onto an unknown dimension
this unknown dimension is characterized
by the presence of a large quantity of
red smoke
and an unknown number of human voices
screaming from within
document 7 the following is an extract
from the 1972 political work
manifesto for old order by children of
the scarlet king member
adrienne cartwright cartwright's work is
only found in
unpublished copies among anomalous
circles and groups related to scp-1
fragments such as this were recovered by
dr montauk
during the course of this investigation
the sin of modernity is vital to
understand
it is not that we glorify the pre-modern
the suffering was very real and very
excellent
we must not fall into the trap of seeing
the past is a series of
beautiful arcadias full of dancing
around may poles and
shepherds living in pleasant anarchy
the past was brutal but it was also real
it wasn't really the pre-modern too that
is
merely how historians have characterized
it
they are wedded to their theory of
modernization and can conceive of no
alternate mode of development other than
a singular drive
towards the contemporary west with other
modes of living seen as being stuck in
some
imagined earlier place on a timeline
it's all nonsense
the people of the past were capable of
seeing the world as it really is
those of us who have joined the king's
forces can all see
this truth that there is something very
very
wrong with the world in which we live
our buildings are made of calcifying
peeling concrete as we shamble each day
to jobs and lives created solely for the
purpose of maintaining their own system
but there is no other way to live
socialism
anarchism syndicalism these are little
more than constructed
pipe dreams the frail thoughts of lesser
men
trying to impose their antiquated
prejudices on the world around them
no there is only one alternative way to
live
to cast down the law of concrete is to
raise
up the law of blood
we must learn what it is to die to be
enslaved
truly brutally enslaved
with no compassion or compunction from
our masters
we must learn what it is to be taken
towards a single purpose
to know and truly understand our lack
of agency we must be beholden to the
world of gods
and darkness the tempest tossed
refuse of a race of fools we must
kill modernity post-modernity with all
its analysis
and sneering observation there is only
one rule the rule
of chaos for humanity for life
for the scarlet king
[Music]
phase three the howling
document eight the following is an
interview between dr robert montauk
and poi 3172
date 29th of april 2018
interviewer dr robert montauk
interviewee
poi 3172 location site 713
interview room 2.
hello hello dr montauk
i hope our last meeting i'm sorry for my
unprofessional behavior
you you touched on a source subject
of course i will try to refrain from
doing so in the future
shall we begin this time doctor i have a
question for you
indeed i suppose it can't be worse than
your last
well what do you know of the origins
of the scarlet king there are many
theories
a creature from the abyss some shambling
thing of old
a denison of lagada they are all
i will not say lies but the texts have
changed the knowledge has changed the
past itself has been changed by what
came after
he's changed the past no his past has
changed for him
but now you tell me something this
should be a given take after all
this is not why did you approve the
montauk procedure
i'm sorry if i've offended you i thought
i made it clear that this is none of
your business
see the thing i don't get is that it
should not have worked
not in the way the foundation does is
not under discussion
what happened to jacob doctor what
happened to your brother
this interview i'm all right all right
i'm sorry
i'm not trying to hurt you doctor truly
i just
want to understand it's just
it shouldn't have worked the child
should have been born
i i was angry
when i drew it up it was unprofessional
did you think we took jacob well what
the hell was i supposed to think
i start looking into your lot making
discovery after discovery and then he
disa
look this isn't relevant all right all
right i'm sorry i asked
but can we agree that this was not a
decision made scientifically
that it was done in a moment of rage
fury hate
i didn't the girl i didn't mean
you did doctor look i'm sorry
i don't mean to dredge these old wounds
up for you why are you then
because i just want to understand and
now i think i do
how you
i don't know where to begin let me go
back
i don't think your department has very
much activity in recent months
not after the hands attempt to open the
gates right
your procedure keeps the girl from
giving birth
the nomads keep fighting their endless
war the spears are safely locked away by
the book burners and the devourer
well there's nothing you can really do
about the devourer now
is there scp-2317 isn't scp-1
wasn't scp-1
but the thing is you've been telling
everyone he is
technically you're meant to think that
he is
if i understand foundation hierarchies
correctly
you are only a level four after all
i don't understand across every culture
in
every city and tribe and civilization
you've come across the idea
of the scarlet king always the same an
emperor in red
with a burning crown and an ethos rooted
in some
archaic fear of female sexuality
he is always the same a monster that is
all-consuming
and terrible but so understandable
the big bad thing in the dark full of
rape and fire and old blood ritual
does it never strike you as odd that
this
is the thing behind the eyes you've
faced monsters far grander and more
subtle as you've told me yourself
but always always there's that lingering
fear and knowledge of this hidden but
oh so simple thing standing behind it
all
you know what strikes me as odd i told
you as much myself
but i also stopped trying to make sense
of our world a long time ago
the anomalous does not play by the rules
of man
i'm too old to start redefining the
universe but the thing you don't
remember
or don't know is that this wasn't the
only past
the scarlet king used to be something
very different
he wasn't a monarch and he wasn't always
red
he was the whisper on the wind that kept
the peasants working
staring up in fear of his righteous
famine
he was that inborn knowledge of a world
of gods and demons which belialed human
agency and existed beyond us
he was the cold hunger of famine that
had no rhyme and reason
but the cold apathy of a supernatural
beyond us
and given enough belief he could be the
devourer too
he is a creature of truth
you mean it transformed from one type of
deity into another
the scarlet king is not a deity doctor
the scarlet king is an idea
what but he's real physical we've seen i
can't tell you anymore
not yet did you find anything out about
the law of concrete
no not much i found out that there seems
to be a disturbing correlation between
the activities of the king's followers
and certain decisions made by the
council i see
but there wasn't much else at all the
trail led me to some lost documents but
eventually all i found was a dead end a
document about the foundation's origins
and some insane old child ranting on
about modernity
contrite i presume that makes sense
you are a maddeningly infuriating person
you know
why can't you just tell me this stuff
properly i
am your prisoner you did destroy my
life's work
why should i help you because you're
bored
because you think none of this matters
and because you love
tormenting me i don't you know
the scarlet king is an idea what the
hell is that meant to me
you're close now doctor close to the
truth
i can see it in you you will understand
and then you'll understand me why i did
when i did why i am was
a member of the children i know you're
curious
you do seem oddly well adjusted to be a
satan worshipper
be careful doctor the law of the howling
may break you
cryptic is ever spivak all right
until next time goodbye doctor
document nine the following is a
translated excerpt from the 1953 bengali
work
la la raja the work had been lost for
some time and rediscovered by dr
montauk in the course of this
investigation
and so the british rule continued
something began to come with them
piece by piece a shadow at first
read think but it was not whole it was
not even in pieces
it was something that crept up slowly
piece by piece
it met the shadows of our country the
mice
bleeding in the rice fields and it began
to take form
it didn't have a mind not at first it
wasn't enough of a real thing
to have one it was a set of images it
was a blood red
slab of skin taken from the heart of
some christian demon which was set upon
an
ancient magician of hindu rites but then
it was categorized
written down described with precise
scientific terminology
it didn't like that things of magic
technology empire that were never meant
to mix
all came together and began to bend the
nature of the world
as europe king to us more and more as we
learned to be
civilized our religion began to change
too
anantisha was not an ancient and
capricious god in the form of an immense
snake
it was a more eel of scientifically
unusual
size noted for producing amnesiacs and
causing a cognitive hazardous effect
we learned that we were hindu that we
always had been hindu
and that all our various and mixed
beliefs were all variations on a
singular ideal
because the british weren't comfortable
enough with another way of living which
could not be classified
explained killed like a butterfly
pinned to a board but beneath
lay this fury cry for authenticity
for reality even as we expressed
ourselves more and more in their
language and their categories
even in our struggle against them it lay
in our literature
into gore and others it lay on our other
in our menial jobs as clerks
the endless struggling tension between
the old and new
between modernity and pre-modernity and
in those fault lines in that
cry of rage and fury in our hatred of
the old and the hatred of the new
there rose a hybrid obeying nothing but
the law of the howling
there rose the lala raja
because what is he but the cry of a
forgotten
age he is the british peasant staring up
at the red sky
the bengali widow's weeping and shaven
head the aztec
priest ripping out another's heart he is
all those things transformed
as modernity does to everything into
modernity's own destruction
he is the resistance the fury
the hatred of all that was for all that
presently is what we were was
full of good and evil and all else mixed
together
the happiness the beauty of the world
the struggles and heartache and
reality of it all but now we have lost
almost all of it to the machine
except our rage and that's all that's
left
and thus comes the king the howl of the
destroyed and forgotten and oppressed
his only purpose
is to destroy rape maim enslave
and smile smile that smile of a king
whose enemies weep before him
he cannot exist where there is no
modernity
because his entire purpose is given to
him
by modernity he is a god of blood
a god of spine and bone and sinew to
remind the denizens of this world
that it is not good it is cruel
and hateful and that is good that
is right modernity is a sin
and he is the correction so that we can
once again live as we must cold
and hungry and starving and very
very afraid
document 10 the following note was found
in dr montauk's personal quarters
it is believed to have been written
shortly after dr montauk's discovery
of lala raja
scp-1 is a conceptual entity created at
the boundaries of the modern
and the pre-modern the scarlet king
is a thing of blood and bone and sinew
his rule is just the justice of the dark
scp-1 is a creature
emperor a physical being made manifest
in a conceptual
he comes with fear and a sword
dripping with wrath and fire
scp-1 originated in ancient turkmenistan
it is believed that it was originally a
scythian deity who
rode with thunder in their hooves and
the bow on their backs
laughing as they slaughtered
scp-1 is a scientific phenomenon
it will be classified it will be
contained
described it will be understood
as an anomalous entity as with every
other and
but he exists in the cracks the fault
lines
he feeds on description he feeds on
science
on the objective principles and
qualities seven chains
seven brides seven seals
for the scarf i am robert montauk
level four researcher project lead on
scp-1
i am a researcher i impose my solid
mechanical will i am in control
i possess agency i possess agency
i am a quivering thing looking up at a
dark and clouded sky
fearing the almighty god i am free
i am chained i am a doctor
i am a child
document 11. on the 22nd of may 2018
a large crack appeared in the wall of
poi 3172's containment chambers
the crack appeared to open on another
dimension a large quantity of red smoke
could be seen
pouring out of it while an unknown
number of human voices could be heard
screaming from it
foundation staff found themselves unable
to enter poi 3172's containment chamber
poi 3172 informed them that he would
only permit dr montauk
entry into his chamber and would
communicate with nobody else
after some debate dr montauk was
permitted entry into the containment
chamber to interview poi 3172
the log follows date 22nd of may
2018 interviewer dr robert montauk
interviewee pny 3172 location
site 713 humanoid containment chamber
77.
dr montauk enters the chamber and
approaches poi 3172
poi 3172 is standing in front of a
jagged crack
in the far wall red light and smoke can
be seen emerging from this crack
hello there depression hello doctor
always formal even to the last aren't
you
can i ask you what this is
a plea for attention mostly i wanted to
see you again
and my requests were all denied
it's been weeks doctor i i had nothing
to ask you
i thought so you have deduced the truth
haven't you maybe yes
it did that just it grows and shrinks
depending on the situation
different actions have different
meanings and thus
different effects it all depends on
context
the other children never got that but
well
they never got anything really
they thought we were old devil
worshipers heading for violation
only i understood the point
it took me a while to understand i
didn't think you would
just tell me did the procedure even
matter
what we do is it even relevant
to prevent the birth it had to be
something awful
something evil expressed in pain and
rage and fury
that's why it worked it was never a
sincere attempt to formulate a
scientific procedure on your part
it was just pure unadulterated hatred
wrapped in a veneer of objectivity
you thought the king had taken your
brother so you decided to hurt the king
you didn't of course and what you do
each day to that poor little girl is
more than mere cruelty
but effective cruelty
specifics are unimportant but the intent
that matters
for everything i i should stop it
even then what the foundation won't get
it
they will never understand the law of
the howling if i explain
i can't imagine it it's beyond their
conception of reality
but you might so tell me doctor
do you know why the scarlet king exists
because modernity and because the scp
foundation exists
modernity helped shape him defined the
contours of his rage
but it was when modernity started
interfering in his kingdom that he was
crystallized
modernity in the form of you your lot
came
first you came into being to lock away
classify pin down everything that didn't
fit
into your philosophy of enlightenment
rationality
everything had to be understood
contextualized
transformed from fairy and godhood into
simple
comprehensible chunks of logic and
matter
it's abhorrent and it could never go on
forever
something had to give something had to
rise up in opposition
we were first truthfully
i know that bolvoir had was this thing
really our fault
that depends is it your fault if you
don't know you're doing it
i don't know neither do i
the ceremonies they all held that
contrast
the king cannot exist without that
tension
we needed those symbols of modernity
those
stark grey images to make the rift in
the first place
it was the perfect plan but you failed
yes the foundation was formed in the
1820s
it was formed to protect the world by
the dark by a collection of brave men
and women
to secure contained protect
that is our purpose there is a virtue in
normalcy
which i don't think you can see the
world can be understood
truth reason rationality the
enlightenment
these are our bedrock these are what
have allowed us to see what is objective
do you really believe that i have to
you're a scientist you should know that
there's no such thing as an objectively
true finding in any science
there's always room for doubt always
space for error
but that's just humanity we may have
flawed minds
incapable of full interpretation but
what we observe is solid and real
beneath it all the laws the bedrock is
defined
by the number seven seven chains seven
brides seven seals seven seven seven my
whole life has been defined by that
number
it torches me endless heptagonal shapes
dancing behind my eyes
we're not allowed to live we're not
allowed to be people
that is the true luxury of modernity
despite its coldness and its creaking
wounds
to be able to be a full person
seven seven seven seven girls taken away
by raiders in the cold
as the wind demon howled and howled so
the scarlet king had to have seven
brides
modernity is not always cold it's less
brutal than slavery
but what is it for is that the only
purpose
a mere absence of brutality what's the
point of having peace and kindness for
its own sake
so you can smile for a few decades
before falling dead into an empty grave
self-affirmation for a finite self
i don't understand it i never did
i grew up trying i wanted to be like
them
like you but the system just stared down
at me with contempt
maybe it's not coldness doctor coldness
seems to be objective
it can't be that because there is no
objectivity there is just screaming
and the madness and the need for purpose
did you really think that nothing is
true there's truth
but it's never final
there's no ultimate reality doctor no
totality no
concrete way in which the world is run
there's just what we make of it the clay
things we
bind together and crudely make in the
clay
all this introspection
who's in there with him who knows
his seven brides his loyal nomads
ancient servants more creations of the
gap between realities
i don't know anymore it all breaks down
in the end
all i see anymore is the fire
i don't see the worlds or gods or kings
i don't see anything but the flames
what else is there this stuff
mata and the physical all banal or fake
i only see the smile of my king forged
out of burning and frail matter
and it's the sight that hurts
it hurts so much behind the eyes
it is burning and being consumed
and it's never ever finished
then why not stop worshiping him i was a
frail thing
i was born in the cold in the dark
i tried my hand at writing when i was
very young
i tried my hand at many things bartering
starving surviving in the market places
of calcutta
like so many of us struggling to live
while you westerners grew fatter on our
forgotten wealth
i grew mad there was no meaning
no purpose in a country born to be
ripped apart
i tried gods but they were silent
i tried reason and atheism but they were
just as empty and unreal
because they were always going to be
because don't say it you have to hear it
i
i don't no listen robert
just listen you know now what the
scarlet king is
he is a creation of swirling anomalies
of so many different times
all over the world he is the memory of a
world that is lost
the pre-modern world made manifest in a
form of hatred for modernity
the new the humanism and smiling
coldness that marks our day-to-day
existence
forged from a perfect balance of
irreconcilable anomalies
and our breaking minds he is an entity
created by this
overwhelming unavoidable tension
of the howl of the old world when faced
with a cold gray purposeless new
he is the revenge of our fallen past
he is the idea of the ancient in a world
which discards and fetishizes it
he is the tension between the modern and
the pre-modern made manifest
yes he is the fault line between two
irreconcilable worlds and he can only in
the end
destroy them all and that is what is
right
what do we do now you shoot me
let them take my corpse go back to your
life
it won't last long now the king's coming
is inevitable
you might try to do something to stop it
but it won't work
the foundation has too much at stake
too much resting on the preservation of
the ethos
they will coat the world in concrete
gray
and the king will rise from the ashes
and the children won't even have to lift
a finger
i don't believe you believe what you
like
come doctor i think it's time
just look just tell me one more thing
was it you who took jacob no
we had no idea we
dr montauk terminates poi 3172
the crack disappears
document 12. the following is a record
of o5 council vote
number 4985 council vote 4985
vote to approve suggestions made by dr
robert montauk
on foundation operating procedures for
improved containment of scp-1
proposed by o513 on the 30th of may
2018. for two
six seven ten and thirteen against
o five one three eight nine
eleven and twelve abstain o five four
and five vote denied
statement by o51
[Music]
dr montauk's investigations have been
most
illuminating they have certainly raised
some serious concerns
about how the foundation has been
operating in recent years
but we feel his suggestions go
too far the ethos of the foundation
is comprehension postmodern notions of
the fallibility of objective universal
truths are all very well in academic
circles but the foundation has always
been first and foremost concerned with
practicalities basing its analyses on
the hard sciences and unquestionable
truths
changing our intentions and modus
operandi is frankly
an absurd proposition our duty is and
always has been
to die in the dark to protect those in
the light
if we begin to abandon or redefine the
notion of what dark and light are
we risk a sharp descent into tyranny
incoherence
and the loss of our mission entirely
this
must not happen we cannot engage in
cavalier redefinitions of what the
foundation's very
essence is we thank dr montauk for his
work
and we will be accordingly updating
scp-1's classification to safe
as a result of it containing scp-1 is no
longer as difficult as it once was
despite its potential danger if
montauk's information is correct
then it seems clear to us that the
foundation should simply take a more
laissez-faire attitude towards scp-1's
containment
we look forward to a more productive
containment relationship with our oldest
anomaly
going forward
supplementary voice log found playing
now
i watched hidden as their bulldozers
came
prime land wasted on trees they said
they ripped them up sliced their roots
took them away to be made into tables
chairs and other menondis then over
weeks and months
they flattened it they poured concrete
into the rest it was scraped and shaped
come into neat little squares arranged
precisely
and in an orderly fashion walls rose up
great walls of concrete windows their
measurements precisely regulated
a series of standardized bricks for
other parts construction crews
and workmen and all the rest working
efficiently and precisely for a long
time
filling in the details the furnishings
and precise abstract wallpapers
and everything else that went into
making a facility
finally it was finished one single
new tree had been planted in the center
of the central courtyard
not through any sense of whimsy or
delight but to give those within a
little sense of nature
of reality in the center of the gray to
keep them sane
nothing more a precisely mandated
allowance for the improvement of human
mental health
until they can find out a way to phase
that out entirely
i watched and i thought about all that
they
that we had done i thought about the
world they wanted
i thought about their spinelessness i
knew what good was
and what evil was and i saw none of it
in either of them
i thought about hollow men made of straw
plastered together with thick paste and
sold in a hundred
a thousand identical ways in a thousand
identical shops
i thought about what we had lost and i
howled
at night the day before the site's grand
opening i dug up the seeds of the tree
and replaced them with a seed of my own
devising
and oversight 231 will stand a thing of
blood
and bone and sinew a tree that drips
and layers and feeds it will drip
strange fire
and that fire will both burn and warm in
equal measure
and they will look up at it and wish
they had listened while they had the
chance
[Music]
i know this path is wrong but at least
it's a path
with thoughts and prayers robert montauk
child of the scarlet king
i would like to give a special thank you
to
banker zargaram
professor puffer the morrigan
retalias karim el hashmuy
big onion bean sayo dio denatus
revenant brian sanchez
matthew gilmore eric corbidge
kawaii fire keeper longinus
carcass death aqua king madding
james saba nj vojak
and oblong doucheboy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen thank you
you